so today we're starting a moral theory
called hedonism and we're looking at
this today for two ancient philosophers
and their schools next week we're going
to start two weeks where we look at a
particular variety of even as I'm called
until it's hairy missile that introduces
another twist to it and that's going to
be the Bentham and mill but today we're
looking at the ancient proponents of it
so we're looking at this guy eros
stiffest
and his ceramic school and then we're
looking at Epic Urist who started you
know the whole epicurean tradition what
all these these guys have in common
they're all hedonists and the BIA
hedonist means to think that pleasure is
the fundamental good sometimes we use
that term today
pejorative where you say if somebody is
a hedonist we mean that they're just
demoted and pleasure and we probably
mean that they make a lot of bad choices
you know as a result by sacrificing all
sorts of other things directly for
pleasure
that's not necessarily what a hedonist
would do but some humanists are likely
right so this whole notion of eat drink
and be merry that Shakespeare quote goes
because tomorrow we're gonna die that
would be a humanistic way of approaching
us and one way of thinking about game is
we're going to use this intrinsic and
instrumental good distinction if you're
a humanist than all the other good
things and you can recognize those
things as good things but all of the
good things are merely in are merely
instrumental goods to give yourself what
really matters the intrinsic pleasure
that's what makes you eat is to say that
pleasure it is the good the fundamental
good is equivalent to saying that all of
the goods are instrument
friendship friendships are good things
but why are they good for hedonist
because they bring pleasure you didn't
want to wear another maybe you like
hanging out with your friend they're
enjoyable or maybe you get things from
your friend you don't really like your
friend that much but you know you get
things that are pleasurable from them
they would be instrumental good we
talked about this last time why do
people like food drink wine stuff like
that because of the pleasure that brings
why do we like watching TV because it
gives us pleasure so there's a lot of
the kinds of pleasures but ultimately
they would be the only things that are
truly valuable everything else would be
valuable just because they lead to it
and if you could get the pleasure
directly why not cut out the
instrumental or if you have to sacrifice
something what are you a sacrifice
you're knocking sacrifice the pleasure
you're gonna sacrifice the other words
so if a friendship gets in the way of
your greater pleasure sacrifice that
friendship right yeah
one pleasure that's lesser in intensity
gets in the way of another pleasure
sacrifice them lesser pleasures for them
for the greater pleasure that's what he
gave miss exactly so now if pleasure is
the good what would be the bad exactly
yeah
so if pleasure is the fun enough good
then experiencing pain would be the
worst thing now if you're a hedonist
that would mean that there would be
other trade-offs to get away from pain
anything that you could do to lessen the
amount of pain that you feel would be a
good thing that would also be instrument
and there's a lot of things we talked
about this before uh Madison right you
guys like taking medicine why do you
take it
because it makes you feel this let's
walk when you're sick right so we do
some things in order to gain pleasure we
do other things in order to avoid paint
or prevent or alleviate pain and that's
pretty much it from a hedonist
perspective that's moral universe and
everything fits into that now we're
going to look at two different
approaches to this and they are quite
distinct and they really do diverge from
each other so I'm going to tell you a
little bit about these these two guys in
their schools before we do that so that
might help you keep them accordingly so
erysipelas was another student of
Socrates Plato wasn't the only person
who followed Socrates and then he
founded his own philosophical school
there were a number of different people
who did that and then some other to get
that other things like identifying as a
historian it was also a military officer
also the bike bells of my days was sort
of a student of Socrates who managed to
screw up Greek politics for at least a
couple generations
he wasn't the philosopher here a
stiffness was the philosopher and he was
kind of a rich guy and he focused
primarily on pluggin I'm living a life
that was as pleasant as possible that's
the message that he got from Socrates
that was the good life
so he must have been you know he ran
very very different things than play
them in some respects all right Plato's
but that's what eras tipis came up with
and then he founded a school that's
called the serie dance school why
because it was in serial location and
this continued for a long time as a
major school in ancient thought they
were all hedonist they said
so you should live a life waiting paint
that the curious is coming later he is
closer in time to Plato student
Aristotle so you're looking at a
difference of a couple generations and
Epicurus found in another major school
of philosophy some people thought that
he was associated with the era stiffest
but he's really quite different and
here's the fundamental difference
between the two of them aris tipis is
going to say that physical pleasure is
more intense is better than mental
pleasure or pleasures of the soul
however you want to figure and if that's
the case then what should we pursue we
should pursue physical pleasure right
and if we have to sacrifice mental
pleasure for physical pleasure we should
take the physical pleasure and if we
have a chance to pursue it directly why
not do that he you know Aris tifus was
actually criticized in a quote that I
gave you for hanging around prostitutes
and taking them in and living with them
and things like that and there's tip the
said you know if you want pleasure
directly this is one really good way to
do that I don't have to go through all
the hoops that other people have to go
through it aren't as satisfy my you know
sexual desires I can take care of it
right away and then I can experience
some other pleasures he was being
consistent with his philosophical a lot
of people think that's because they had
other moral theories there's no way
Epicurus would have said anything like
that
why because Epicurus thought that mental
pleasures and levy ation of mental pains
was much better yeah
so with Arastoo piss you've got one kind
of hedonism there that the curacy of
another community but they're both
hedonist and that they think that
pleasure is the fundamental good it's
just what kind of pleasure are you going
to make your life scent your mouth so
this is a good point to like think about
these questions that you remember back a
couple class sessions who asked these
questions who raised them first reading
that he wasn't Socrates that was later
on again
no maca time yeah yeah it was MacIntyre
and engineers said every moral theory is
asking these two fundamental questions
as well as other questions and every
human being of course their life asks
these in a very specific way what is the
good for human beings
well even ISM says pleasure another way
to think about this if you want to
broaden it further is happiness
the hedonist wants to be happy they have
a particular conception of what
happiness consistent this is very
curious and Epictetus are going to be
different for each other happiness for
sorry at the charism here a stupas
epictetus is somebody you're gonna relay
around here instead of stinks that
happiness consists in one particular way
of experiencing pleasures
Epicurus thinks it's a different way so
once you've got that figured out that
doesn't solve everything for you
right you have to ask the southern
question okay I know what the good is
we've got that straight how do I get it
what do I have to do in order to be
happy that way and this is a question
about how you arrange your life how you
wave things against each other how do
you value things what sacrifices you
make when you pursue what you reject
this is where it gets down at war
meeting grid right there's one thing to
know what you want to pursue it's a
whole different thing to figure out how
you're going to get there and these two
are going to differ on that as well in
part because they have different
conceptions of happiness so before we
actually go into each of their their
ideas let's let's look at some of these
pleasures or Pleasant experiences you
guys have over the weekend and I'll
start out by telling you about something
that I found particularly
just in part two to help you see what I
have when I'm driving like this
so yesterday I went to the girls
basketball game
it was faculty Appreciation Night so
they sent us emails that said you can
get free tickets and I thought it could
be fun you know embarrass is a good
school for athletics so there's probably
a good chance that you know they'll play
well you haven't been to a basketball
game for a long time I don't like
watching basketball on TV I find it very
boring but I do like watching it in the
stands and in person yeah you can get
two tickets I probably wouldn't go on by
myself anyway
but I went with my wife and it would
sort of be not even any really big date
that because one of the things that you
have to really make sure that you do
you'll experience this when you're when
you're married is during the courtship
here you have lots of dates right but
then after a while when you're married
you have to make sure they make time for
that sort of thing so this was an ideal
opportunity to do that we both would
work all the time and we thought this
would be a good occasion to do that so
we went to the game and it was you know
it was a lot of fun we went in a lot of
alumni students the band was playing the
band is really good and we had we got
situated I went down got some got some
good Gatorade for me and a soda for her
and then we sadly watched the game and
it was a lot of fun because you know
first the the opposing team the st.
Peter's PN's
their Jersey they speak him out they
start beating the Marist the Maris got
into it and they just roust up by the
end of the game they have like 80 points
the other team was in the 30s I think
18-49 Oh 49 okay yeah and they were you
know they just play it way better and
they they had some really good blocks
and no defense and and I think it really
helps that home-field advantage we have
a band like that that plays all these
songs and actually heckles the other
team while they're doing it and you know
they did the typical sort of things with
having you know contests here and there
so a lot of spectacle stuff right yeah
and so it was very fun I was there you
know my wife we got spend some time
together doing something so now what was
the thing about what were what were the
pleasures involved with that it wasn't
just one pleasure yeah yeah so there
that's an important part friendship
companionship even perhaps a little you
know developing intimacy or something
like that right yeah oh I do like
getting free things and then Mary you
know nobody ever brought that up when
I've mentioned this in the other class I
actually get a kick out of my bar games
and stuff like that so you're right
there is a pleasure that comes with that
for being yeah yeah and more than one
kind of entertainment right there's the
spectacle of the game you have won a
contest you get to see people who've
been training not only themselves from
their bodies but with with everybody
else competing against each other that's
a lot of fun that's why we like to watch
much sports it's also why we like to
watch things like American Idol that's
also competition
yeah an embarrassed alumni and students
seem to be particularly good at that it
was a very enjoyable experience yeah
say when yeah
waiting is plus losing is not right
so that's a that's a sweet a whole bunch
of different pleasures well what are
some of the things that you enjoyed this
weekend okay a lot of people said you
watch it
so Super Bowl parties with us
okay yeah I want to losing my friends
okay
so let's think about what's what's
pleasant about what's enjoyable its what
are the components so Super Bowl parties
yeah might be might be drinking yeah I
would say like the atmosphere like
nobody's really everybody's like
carefree at a party yeah be able to
relax enjoy yourself but at least while
the Super Bowl is going on - nothing
about homework you have to do stuff I
need to put into I learn what else what
else the people have it Super Bowl
parties that makes it yeah yeah so it's
better if you have a wide variety right
you know you don't want to be the person
just bring them back into Rito's
not the desert you know wings dip where
else we had Graz Itza yeah okay they'll
be good or evil wow that's that's pretty
good today and we only had a sailor who
didn't have any sweet desserts but I
supposed a to bring a whole bunch of
sweet desserts as well imagine with the
Super Bowl parties of the people at the
culinary snacks they promise your trash
well this is quite a few different
pleasures we're going to the game of
Nazca Square Garden
there's probably a lot of solar things
right which components would fit in
there watching the actual game watching
the Giants won yeah it's for most of you
three
I was just saying I don't have a dog in
this fight right on the African side I'm
rooted for the Giants myself but that's
good you know NFC versus AFC so I'm not
from here so for your right nobody does
they're sort of like the Cowboys like
the AFC so event is here so the same
stuff pretty much as Super Bowl party
you think or anything different
any additional they don't know what word
you can use but just environment of
being at Madison Square Garden just like
they stand I think your bright lights
let's call that yeah you know one of the
things that somebody else brought up was
having a nice meal on restaurants and I
said you know you paid for atmosphere
you don't just pay for the food itself
you pay for how it's plated music that's
around look for the place the feel the
place the server's the rhythm you're
paying for all those sort of things
because we find those enjoyable
oh yeah that would be like these thank
you
getting them getting away from things
but maybe changing location away from
the house the same town yeah what you're
saying about atmosphere if you like
changing location it's kind of the same
thing because earlier you were like
doing watching basketball on TV but the
game I don't I can't watch it on TV
but if somebody says do you want to go
I'll be off everything go yeah I didn't
say what I can't stand it up to get some
little boring thing he's so slow but if
you're there in the stands and you know
there's all you're surrounded by all
these other people that are watching the
game and there's you know the hotdogs
and all this other stuff and the other
nice open here there's something to that
experience that we find that pleasant
right but maybe some things we also find
the painful
they got interested what about visiting
your friend I think there's probably
some elements to that so visiting a
friend - well you have the friendship
aspects well what else is pleasant yeah
it's kind of like feel like when you
visit back home it's kind of like all
the good memories that you've had about
that come back to you
I don't know how to explain it now
there's no situations so yeah you expect
good out of it basically when you share
common experiences common even kind of
language like you know I don't know did
I ever tell you about this story when
when my now wife and I first talked on
the phone
so we're from about 20 miles apart in
the stats we went to the same place
that's where we actually I was my
sophomore year in freshman yeah we never
dated in high school
and then we sort of parted ways and then
we both worked in the same office
building about five years the afterwards
in Milwaukee
third shift actually flirted with each
other didn't realize we chose work both
dating other people at the same time
yeah and then much much much later on
thicker news after that we end up
reconnecting and we did it at first
entirely through text we didn't we
didn't talk to each other on the phone
we first used Facebook yeah you know the
message function of Facebook we actually
broke that there's a certain limit for
words and if you go beyond them they cut
you off they assume that you're spamming
or stalking the other person oh wait no
we were writing back and forth because
we were infatuated with each other you
know you know right yeah so we were
writing back and forth all the time so
that that we couldn't do that anymore
and I remember the feeling that came
with that when I realized we couldn't
link to each other anymore because
Facebook and like you know gotten the
wrong message and then she was really
smart she created a private blog that we
can use to write as much as we wanted to
each other and then we started doing
Google chat because that was real time
we still haven't talked to each other on
the phone and then finally one day same
day Thursday a couple years ago she
texted me earlier texted of course and
she said what do you think about talking
like actually talking yeah so I said
yeah okay let's let's do that and we
were both so nervous that we saw at the
time it supposedly owned like a phone
game right it's not the time that we
won't make sure that we had something to
do with their hand so we won't have like
a dish that we were preparing whether
it's talking on the phone now as soon as
I talk to her yeah I heard that
Wisconsin accent it was like home and
and there was something different about
that that all the other stuff that we've
done up to that point so that's it's
very difficult to put that in borders I
think it's difficult to communicate
exactly what that pleasure is but that's
an intense
isn't it I think all of you know that
there's some place that review is home
now there are people that signify that
yeah older than you get the more
pleasant you'll find in this thing
people talk about the past anything else
that would be particularly pleasant that
we don't already have when you might
have a drink with your friend that's
probably your probably nail I'll go in
Atlantic City
what what else would be in there besides
good food and drink friendship getting
away from things maybe see a show okay
that's good
additional thing meaning that anybody
likes that right some people are kind of
shy they they don't like meeting new
people other people
I'm guessing yourself myself enjoying
meeting new people you know finding out
who they are where they come from what
makes them tick
I probably ask people too many questions
myself but I was going on
that's a pleasure for those who like
what else might you do in Atlantic City
well you know it's risk right you get a
charge on doing it I don't like it
myself because I always lose what's up
yeah I find the losing money and losing
the game more painful than the
enjoyments of gambling so you notice
there's a trade-off there right but a
lot of people do pretty good and some
people will actually just they enjoy the
gambling so much they don't care for
this and some people can set themselves
in limits like I'll go in they'll say
I'll go in and I'll spend a hundred
bucks and once I get through that
actual party we went to island bar out
in Pennsylvania be careful that Mike his
brother like they gamble like every
other weekend so they have been out what
part yeah that's it it's kind of just
like a it's just it's a hobby at some
point or some people don't like to do it
every once in a while and they always
lose
but if it's a hot issue I have a friend
like she's a she's a philosopher and she
has a dad who's a professional gambler
and she knows not count cards so she
goes in she's actually been kicked out
of like I casino before because they
caught her counting cards she goes in
and she plays blackjack and she needs
money the thing is for me that would
like take away some of you can join them
just because you'd actually like happen
paying attention all the counting things
I guess once you get really good at any
dessert there are different pleasures
for different people and I notice look
at all these different pleasures that
we've already laid out with just a few
experiences how heterogeneous how a
wider range of pleasures which of these
are purely physical pleasures and which
are much more mental pleasures
and you know we could quibble about
something like this like you know let's
say you take drinking right drinking is
primarily a physical pleasure there may
be some mental aspects to it if you're a
wine connoisseur you know and you're
testing your knowledge or something like
that sure there could be some some
mental aspects are studying the wine but
for the most part why do we drink
because we like drinking a drink tastes
like the alcohol it could contribute to
other pleasures like you know objective
socialized food is primarily a physical
one right we eat because we enjoy the
taste it may not just be gustatory maybe
factory our sense of smell is tied in
could be tactile the way it feels
could be visual you know a good
presentation something like that I don't
know if any of you've seen that famous
photograph with McDonald's pink
substance McNuggets used to be made of
creating rows if you actually saw a
picture of that next to the food when
you were consuming it you would probably
say I don't want to eat this no tastes
pretty good it's great okay
entertainment like you're watching the
Super Bowl it's probably pretty
piss-poor what about the feeling of
victory is that primarily a physical
thing is that more about mental yeah
I can see what that you're playing how
much you're invested we've determined I
guess calm intensities determine not
sure because you're playing when there's
there's there's physical activity that's
wonderful especially if you're in good
shape
there's something beyond that painting
victory yeah I was gonna say if your
players victory you use more than just
the one in itself it's all your hard
work
hey that's right so you get satisfied
mentally but your hard work and if
you're like a spectator like a fan yeah
you're mentally basically happy about it
because hey this is my team and that's
my time I watched them all time I come
here I family and I'm glad they're
actually winning you know yeah
experience that some teams fans are
often deprived
think about that I mean there could be
physical components to it you got it you
know you can actually like talk with the
person and that helps to be face-to-face
where the cell phone well your
friendship is something more in mind
than it is in the body I mean you might
do physical things with your friends
like you can get together and wrestle
with that or something like that some
friendships are romantic you know but
there are you talking about a different
kind of pleasure some pleasures are
mental some pleasures atmosphere I mean
it's physical elements right they
arrange physical space but it's maybe
the emotional the aesthetic effect on
you that you care about we wanted to
make a rigid distinction I just want you
to see them first of all there's an
awful lot of different kinds of
pleasures with you and second that we
can make a distinction primarily the
reason I want to be able to make that is
on these two guys that the curious of
Epicurus eres fitness
one favor is one kind of pleasure or
pain one favors the other we look at
their aesthetic piece is a physical
pleasures or pains are more intense and
mental things so think for example about
a trade-off that he made having to do
with physical pleasure and mental pains
I brought the fact that people you know
have made fun of him and criticized him
because of hanging around his
prostitutes and his the answer it was
white people hanging around prostitutes
it's not just for the you know pleasure
of their conversation it's to have sex
with them ultimately right otherwise we
call them something different so sexual
pleasure that's particularly intense
Louis would come with I mean you can
think of something he might have to
spend in order to get that money right
spend money
maybe that's a little bit of pain or
lack pleasure because you could be
spending the money on something also
pleasant for himself like a whole bunch
of candy bars or a small portion of a
new car or you know take it to a game or
something like that so there there's
some pleasure that's before long for
that but if we're going to experience a
much greater pleasure what else is going
on there people are criticizing right so
how's that make you feel well then even
though and they potentially you may not
like it it's okay because he's getting
the more intense physical pleasure which
is better which is the sexual pleasure
yeah well what would it what pain would
be the experience we want to lay this
all up people are criticizing him how do
you feel like people criticize you
okay so locals call it self-conscious or
he feels a sense of shame and that's a
here's a physical here's a mental pain
that's not mental pleasures you know
mental pains are not as bad so you know
if pursuing a particular pleasure is
shameful but it's really an awful lot of
pleasure then it's a good trade-off you
have to sacrifice people liking you but
who cares that's not that people well
your compared to enjoying you know sex
or good food or drink or whatever
whatever are there physical pleasures
you want to the next so you would if you
were hair stiffness you would say this
is a good trade-off
this is rational to do this makes sense
this is good practical reason the way
your pleasures and pains and you decide
for the ones that are going to actually
bring you the greater pleasure because I
think that played a role yeah yeah
without it you can get bottom without
friends for a while
- to afforded the pleasure that that
outweigh the pain I think there's
something to what you're saying yeah and
I think that the amount of pain could
feel spending time with probably very -
if you if you have to make a trade-off
between providing for your children or
satisfying your new habit whatever it is
that's a much bigger thing than been
using your disposable income that you
weren't going
you're justified savings it's a much
different kind of so I think you I think
what you're saying is possible maybe
Kevin be a rich man they need to thank
some people who espouse this kind of
philosophy and
pleasures yeah me isn't it really just a
way to justify what you're doing well
yeah little Theory ought to be able to
do that right you're saying he's just
rationalizing right what I wanted
studies he's like well this is what I'm
doing people hate it well but this is
what's going on so I'm gonna keep doing
this deal well that would be very
similar to the way you were saying these
would all be sort of explanations of why
he put forth this docket we could
consider though let's say we put that
aside we can think about does this still
make sense even you know if you did that
could it could it make sense for
somebody else could it be a good moral
fear what say we took Arastoo Poisson I
told you would it have made any
difference to the moral theory itself no
these are all interesting historical
facts it may be and it may be in fact a
lot of people who take this on just do
it just to rationalize their their
desire to adults themselves but I think
there are some people who actually do
believe this so we're looking at it as a
theory there's one other thing I want to
I want to get out of this if you hold
this sort of dear well you would want to
experience
physical pleasure a little physical pain
as possible
and here's an interesting problem you
come next to me how long does that play
your lives
fast he's focused on physical you're
right
the memory of the pleasure goes not much
longer that's why that's why there's a
whole bunch of food people who were
talking about these meals that they had
back in 1960 and he doesn't dismiss it
entirely but he's honored to say if you
have the choice between a physical
pleasure or a mental clutter take the
physical because it's going to be more
intense yes and but once you have
experienced that physical pleasure that
you're always going to have the mental
yeah I mean historically he didn't get
in things he thought that and this may
have been uh this may actually about
peculiar any of this guy that things
didn't stick within there are some
people like there are other people who
they don't seem to be very very much
enjoying something at a time
but let's go back to this so if we want
to live a life according in here
statisti much physical pleasure is
possible one of the issues with physical
pleasure is it has to be repeated over
and over and over if you want to be
continually experiencing physical
pleasure you have to be constantly
finding ways to give me a stimulant okay
works that way for food it works at
laical or drink or any sort of drug that
you were going to take it works that way
for for sex it was up made for the
pleasures that come with physical things
like laying in the Sun or sleeping or
getting a massage listening to music you
know turn the music off you're no longer
experiencing the pleasure right so
there's two things that are said this
says about this one is if you're going
to follow this sort of lifestyle you
should pack in as much physical pleasure
as you possibly can and set your leg up
so you're not just going to experience
it right now if you know you guys are
right you would want to structure the
life that you not only can experience
physical pleasure in their twenties
thirties forties or fifties all the way
to allamani so you probably would want
to avoid certain physical pleasures
wooden wagon hook Democrat we're here
right because that's pretty boring
format you know any of the big three
because then your life is pretty much
done why do people like these things
because they are intensely pleasurable
they you know they they stimulate the
pleasure centers of the brain and almost
immediately there's reasons why people
get hooked up my I had a cousin actually
to try to opium once and he said I would
never do that again I was happy I said
it was that good that I know that I
couldn't trust myself that if I ever
so there are certain things you would
have one button generally you would try
to structure life to experience as much
as possible the other thing that Eris
did that says is very few people are
able to do this and this might go to
having the wealth helps out an awful lot
but that doesn't so it may be a very
difficult way to live things out
maybe people who adopt this don't
realize how difficult it would be to
actually make it possible
let's look now at Epicurus Epicurus is
taking a different position era stuff
isn't saying physical pleasures means
much more intense curious he's different
from eros nificent - really
once and it also is saying something I
didn't put this on the board Eris tip
the spot that you got pleasure
you got pain and then there's something
in between which is neither pleasure nor
pain it's a sort of a resting state
Epicurus says no actually if you so if
you aro Snippets if you take away pain
that doesn't bring plenty that just puts
you in this restaurant state
Epicurus says no if you actually take
away pain that itself is this makes
sense think about some physical
pleasures you're really hungry think
about how good it feels to eat them
right you're really thirsty think about
how good it feels to drink it's not just
that the pain goes away
you actually feel a sense of pleasure
don't you think about when you really
really tired and you're striking out
then working upon you just want to sleep
so so bad and then you get in bed
doesn't that feel good just to lay down
just to close your eyes for a minute
maybe Epicurious is right now Epicurus
so epicgoose thinks that mental
pleasures are more attempt what does he
mean by mental pleasures what's what he
has in mind are things like learner you
know when you actually learn something
you acquire and get it
you yourself find pleasurable satisfying
and engaging your going to keep thinking
about that idea because you like
thinking about that idea turn it over in
your head look at it from different
angles and aspects and you're gonna dig
into it you're gonna learn more and
learn more about it all of you have
experienced this right you may not
epochs may not be your cup of tea
philosophy may not be your cup of tea
but all of you have a major are all of
you happy with your major I hope so if
not maybe pick a different major right
because because you should study
something that you really like and
that's pleasurable and that is going to
stick with you and sustain you
what are some other I'm not sure
security yes as a matter of fact the
Greeks got a word for that that the
Epicureans uses ox rocks and not being
troubled being being less yeah they
didn't talk about being stressed out not
being stressed out yeah that's that's a
mental plan that's not physical I mean
we have a physical core of up to that
the body's not being put under
for things like that that doesn't feel
that great except you know when you're
stopping exercise there's nothing to say
running away from somebody and you don't
want to have to run but the not being
trouble is that being stressed out by
this
Epicurus thinks that's intensely
pleasurable all your experience right
maybe not so much with students yeah
when you've got all your assignments
done wave advance and you're always late
for the test you've got the study sheets
ready
that would be what you're talking
probably the best management it was when
you were like five and you didn't have a
care in the world
yeah unless you were kidding yeah a lot
of us when we think back to our
childhood we have a fairly happy
childhood sometimes even if we've walked
out the other parts
we think of it as a time when we didn't
have responsibilities I actually you
know it's interesting as a professor I
think about when I was a graduate
student and I didn't have to be prepared
every day and give lectures and grade
students you know essays and stuff like
that and I just had to write my own
paper and read whatever I wanted to read
and show up for class and be more or
less you know prepared how carefully my
life was you know did I really feel like
that
now maybe we maybe we we project that
backwards these times but you know if
your abacus you don't want to be working
for a time you want that to be something
that you're gaming so hopefully your
your majors will actually allow you to
live a life that's fairly stress-free
so yeah another one other pleasure that
we could talk about friendship
friendship is a primarily mental
pleasure that can go on lasting actually
even beyond the death of the person you
can have good thoughts about right
I guess your relationships with your
families with the friendships like so
have the curious things that you've
walked to if you have to choose one of
the other you want to choose mental
pleasures they last longer than more
intense they're also less likely to
bring about pains so let's think about
some physical pleasures and some of the
things that they might pleasure oh yeah
we'll talk about mental aids in a moment
the curious thinks that they do indeed
their difficulty and a lot of the
epicurean philosophy they see in like
the principle doctrines is trying to
steer you out of some things that cause
you mental
but we'll get to that we'll get to that
you're right if mental pleasures are
more intense
think about will take two these will be
kind of a funny stock things you can
think of pains that you have to our
planet pain to have to endure pleasures
that you have to forego in order to get
a pleasure you can think of ways the
pleasure itself could like go off the
rails
not work out the way that you hoped it
did and then you didn't think of bad
consequences painful consequences that
can come so let's take getting drunk
right now why do people get drunk well
cause it's fun
you know people like like drinking
because it makes it any body feel a
different way and a lot of that that's
pleasurable you know provide enough yeah
well you know the first couple drinks
good time sociable like adventures of
one form or another you know but what do
you have to do generally in order to get
that that's right what do you have to
give up right in one way or another
I mean if somebody's giving you free
drinks they're not really free you have
to give them something in return
enjoy just passing the time look but you
have to have to give something up and
then hop and things go wrong when you're
out drinking before I like you that the
morning after what are some things that
might go wrong just in the mall
alcohol does don't worry your decision
you might get fried
yeah well somebody actually might get in
a fight with you you know somebody else
is drunken you look at them and they
think you're who can have the Roger now
well sort of things happen yeah
something they are buying around for
everybody you realize that thirty people
in the bar yeah furnace of antimony when
whatever you do drunk sometimes yeah
that's the decision-making ability gets
lower right maybe the the bartender
doesn't mix the drinks or the cups are
dirty and you get sick as a result you
know we need the markers it's been out
there for five hours
these are all things that could happen
and then what are going to likely
consequences drinking what was the one
that you know this video hey and
hangover is a physical pain all set of
physical and soul it's in your stomach
some of it's in your head because
alcohol is a poison and you in effect
poison your body to get the the brief
charge of the physical charge on that
there might be other consequences too
maybe you did get in the fight you wake
up you know outside in the gutter you
could wake up in bed next to somebody
the next morning I know who they are
be happy with who they are you could
wake up and your car is somewhere else
who knows you are tomorrow yeah we could
be at that role all sorts of things
could happen
and most of those are physical pains
there could be some mental pains that
result from this that's a shame yeah one
mental will be like friends oh you gotta
go find a friend yeah you realize that
what you did was wrong
some are actually thinking about sure
that you feel regret
sometimes a secret will come out with
your dropping you know say you were
going to say and that could ruin a
friendship so they're you know drinking
alcohol by itself is pleasurable but
it's a pleasure that often times risks
being mixed with a lot of paints some of
them are guaranteed to go and if you
drink enough to get wrong you will have
a it works that way there's a lot of
other physical pleasures if you indulge
in and eating too much good food what
happens yeah and then you don't feel
good you know there's there's diseases
that can come with that and have you
ever heard of gout there's a popular
disease back in the 18th century because
they were getting a lot of meat the
causes intense pain in the legs somewhat
bad meet up at the culinary you know
they talk about the freshman 15 here you
know other colleges it's like the
freshman 25 to 30 because you have to
taste all these great dishes but there's
a trade-off right physical pleasures
will often tend to have consequences and
Epicurus talks about this and he has a
way of thinking about this he talks
about pleasures that are natural
unnecessary pleasures that are natural
but not necessary and then pleasures
that are neither necessary nor natural
or realize that's a lot of animals all
thrown in together so it's hard to keep
them straight what we're natural and
necessary of pleasure a success those
that if we don't satisfy we feel pain
like hunger right or thirst sexual
desire yeah
although he seems to have been abstinent
more or less so he seems to know the
interesting thing is some people might
say well I won't get my a my drug I feel
awful physical families you know
somebody who's addicted to heroin for
example will in fact that waffle think
actually even if you're just addicted to
nicotine you quit smoking you're gonna
feel lousy and you're gonna feel
cravings that are very intense that
McCarron kind of things yeah it's not an
it's not an actual natural thing because
there's nothing you know natural about
human beings it's not part of our nature
to need to smoke it's something that we
have actually did and we did it because
it was pleasant and then we came to
desire it but you know if you were an
epicurean you would probably want to
avoid that sort of thing here's here's
one way of thinking about these things
you have to eat right if you don't eat
how do you feel
run down then it starts to hurt and then
when you do eat it feels good do you
need to eat anything fancy when you're
really hungry the oatmeal and
you're really hungry I don't like if I'm
really hungry I can be okay with oh
that's a natural and necessary pleasure
eating a good meal that's cooked the way
that you like it that's natural but
that's not necessary
rich foods are not necessary they are
something that our nature craves you
like sweet stuff
who doesn't like sweets do you like
fatty foods that makes food taste good
that's that's part of it you like salty
things salt makes things taste good too
but we don't actually need that much of
them that's not it's not necessary
instruments and then when you eat do you
need a you know gold plates that's
neither necessary nor natural all right
certainly not natural human beings you
know back to caveman days didn't have
plates at all as far as we know they
certainly weren't gold plates and most
people don't have gold plates even today
yeah every holiday really just like
China you know yeah yeah at the curious
would say those are those are the kind
of things that we probably should do
without if we want to live a genuinely
pleasant life because people get really
worked up about that you know they allow
themselves to feel mental pains over
whether they have physical things
whether they're getting access to
certain desires that really you know
don't don't have anything to do with the
good life let's talk really quickly now
about mental pains that the curious
things that the happy life you want to
be you don't want to add physical pains
right so you want to avoid food that's
going to give you a gallon or drink
things like that you're not gonna keep
very rich fare when it comes to clothing
you don't really need a lot of fancy
clothes
I apologize sitting fashion design
majors here Epicurus is not the guy for
you over no eres tempest would be the
guy for you because it's a yeah we're
all fancy stuff you can get in you're
handsome
Epicurus thinks that you couldn't do
that sweater and this would be in order
to avoid pink this would be over to the
rational life for you you set things up
so that you're going to experience this
much pleasure there's a little pain as
possible what's really what really
affects us our mental mates and what are
the mental pains that he thinks are
worst he doesn't worry so much about
shame or things like that he thinks
about our fears Cain you know we you can
feel physical pain if you fear physical
pain that's often worse than the actual
physical pain you guys probably all
experienced that when you were a kid and
you're scared of the needle for the shot
or whatever it was that you had and then
they actually pushed it into you and
occurred but it wasn't that bad
fearing that can can be worse right
fearing punishment why do people fear
punishment because they do bad things
they do things they shouldn't do there's
there's a way to avoid them don't do bad
things
Epicurus says you know be a just person
and withdraw from society and political
or pangolins as much as possible what's
the biggest fears though he talks about
two other ones and this is my study and
philosophy would be
yeah death is one of the big ones you
remember the other the unknown and what
he means by that you know think about
ancient Greek times they didn't know
what causes thunder and lightning or
hurricanes or stuff like that so they
would have tribute them to the gods and
God seemed to be kind of random yeah and
so you couldn't really depend on them
not to screw you over and so that's
something to worry about that's why he
begins the principal doctrines by saying
gods aren't concerned with us don't
worry about this one
he's actually a materialist so he thinks
that there isn't any afterlife this is
it and this goes to howhow answer is the
issue of death if one of the things that
you're worried about is your own death
but I don't think this is gonna work
very well for other people's deaths of
those concerns but at least for your own
death why don't you have to worry about
that the curious yeah
there's no feeling that you no longer
have a body
yeah when you're done please no you
there's no experience of that we
experience other people that we don't
experience our own death so there's
nothing to actually fear I'm not sure I
find that it's just
yeah we shouldn't fear the unknown when
I get stuff with also you know I hear
about when it comes to my own death it's
not actually any bad things for me it's
bad things for my kids and that does
actually life insurance so maybe
Epicurus can't address all this but at
least you do see what he can address
this is a coherent moral theory this is
hedonistic approach you notice that
Epicurus and eros dip us two very
different interpretations right being a
hedonist doesn't necessarily mean being
committed to a life of physical pleasure
and forget all the mental cultivation
you know I often pose this in terms of
beer or books which is which is the
pleasant life maybe it's Epicurus would
definitely say the books eros tipis was
dead would definitely say all right